when you're a a catch yeah you're a
prized man you have the pick of the
letter you can choose anybody so should
he say celibate
yes he will he has not stopped no
no
as a man you should be disciplined and a
disciplined man can get far in life and
he doesn't he has to deal with a lot of
things he has to deal with a lot of
things and this is the problem she's not
so funny
they kind of lack discipline when it
comes to certain behaviors you say
you don't understand a man's nature you
know for you to say that you don't
really understand a man's nature because
um
when men like general now this is
generally like no i'm saying generally a
man's nature yeah is to have sex yes
this is general nature but the thing is
when you get put in a position of power
you as a woman would have no idea
the amount of women that are coming for
that man of power as a matter of fact
tiger woods can be married all married
men regardless of how much power they
hold they've got a bunch of women that
are just looking to have sex with that
man and so men
being men yeah in positions of power
sometimes
they say okay i'll take the option it
doesn't mean because you took the option
that you now have to have um in these
days and times that you now have to have
a baby yeah yeah well but he was he was
responsible too he's right he used a
condom he wore a condom and and why are
we putting this on the women around the
med why don't we put this on the women
why are we acting like home
like where are we why are we acting like
hoes why are you sleeping
right so basically what it is because
you're confused by the things so
basically he obviously ejaculated in the
condom but afterwards he put hot sauce
in there to basically kill the sperm and
then threw it in the trash but the woman
went in the trash
took a condom out and tried to push it
inside of her and burnt up her thing and
had he not done that she would have had
a baby by him and he would have said if
you if you play it out nine months down
the line he would have said there's no
way that woman's pregnant for my bit for
my opinion because i use a condom
however
once she done a dna test it would have
had his dna and they would have said
drake you're talking lies because the
bottom line is she's got your dna but so
he would have looked like the liar yeah
so
you guys think sorry but do you guys
think that because we had a conversation
the other day was saying like women like
to fight for social justice right and
eventually that helps to change laws why
do men not stand up when things are
happening to them and speak up about it
and have those laws changed it should be
illegal for a woman to take a condom and
shove it up herself and have a baby it
should be legally
maybe it's because it's hard to prove
yeah
record
i'm so caught up in she went in the bin
sorry go ahead
no
as women it's
it's innate in us for us to be able to
talk about
whatever it is you can sit around and
talk about someone you
talk about something with someone you've
known for maybe an hour five minutes
however it is as for men
it's not innate in them to be able to
sit down with their friends like hey yo
this this this this because
it's just
i don't i don't know it's just something
that has been
just shown like oh men shouldn't talk
mention and talk about this mention and
gossip like women around the table but
they do though in private men have real
conversations with their boys about the
women that they're engaging with or do
you know her oh i'm talking to this girl
blah blah they want their friends
opinions as well because if they're
dating a girl or linking her imagine
your boys are saying saying oh that
girl's clapped or she's nasty or
whatever but that's different from
that's different from talking about
issues a lot of men don't talk about the
issues that they have they can talk
about females all day talk about working
out this that in the third second no you
know jesse's right because i went to a
it was called
mantle actually it was in brixton
and i remember those
some professionals up there and they
were discussing about men issues
and it was only till i talked about my
issue
of
the mother not allowed me to see my
daughter the whole energy changed in the
room and there was other men that came
up and started speaking even the two of
the panels that was talking about other
addictions and other issues that they
had didn't feed it upon themselves to
talk about how they seen that child or
the
parental alienation they were facing so
you're writing the zac in terms of what
jessica just said it's i've noticed even
from the back of as i said my podcast
and people have seen
a lot of fathers have reached out to me
that i was surprised and so wow i've
been going through this and they've
wanted to know what things to do
to actually start to see their children
you know it's really deep um it's a
serious subject so i really again have
to say i appreciate your poem you know
sort of talking on it you know what's
interesting so
when i talk about a situation where the
woman is completely in the wrong right
there there's we no one on this panel
would say
that the girl with the hot sauce
situation was in the right like we all
agree she was wrong
but we automatically put the blame onto
men and we say oh well you shouldn't be
dealing with that but earlier when she
was talking about a situation
where she was in it like like he was
completely in the wrong nobody says oh
well you shouldn't have been dealing
with him
exactly
yeah when i went on the podcast the
amount of disgusting comments
that were written under that podcast i
was told that um
god is gonna punish me and i chose to
open my legs and just all these
different things i chose the wrong man i
wanted this person that was like this
and
x y and z without actually understanding
the layers of the situation when i met
this person i was 16. he was a good
eight years older than me that in itself
does not tell you something
but for whatever reason i was getting
all these comments online at me
that
and again it comes to this whole
protection aspect the way i looked at it
was i was 16 and young and i was
in a situation where i felt like he was
protecting me really
he took advantage of the situation and
that is what led on to whatever happened
over the years but when i went on the
podcast what i found quite disappointing
was the fact that
i was attacked online
and
not many people in the comments stood up
for me and this is the issue i feel like
when women do come out and speak
so
it's okay for celebrities to speak but
when real people speak
it's like uh oh my gosh well you should
have seen the red flags and you should
have done this and you should have done
that well i i think it's just like a
level of accountability you know like
like the same way we were holding like
the manic like like to me that that's
the same but i don't think that's the
norm i mean can i add
just to say when you were speaking you
said you know you said celebrities and
then real people and that that concept
in people's mind that's what it is they
separate celebrities from real people
so when i said about drake
the reasons i said that is because he
already had a child in those similar
circumstances do you get what i mean so
him still um putting himself in a
position with oh no he put the hot sauce
i get that but you still but the thing
is regardless of hot sauce or not you're
putting yourself in that position
furthermore the fact that the media has
it to talk about you're putting ideas in
people's head you're actually putting
the idea out into the effort okay and i
find that i should do that yeah and i
think that a lot of these behaviors that
we're seeing with young women in
um young women and men
is it's coming from the fact that the
media kind of projects it into the space
and circulates it on a
a crazy hyper basis but can you imagine
the level of
paranoia
you have to be going through
every time you have sex as drake to
think damn did i put the hot sauce on
the condom this time do you know what i
mean and i think it's unfortunate that
the times in which we live in going back
to the book that i actually said talking
about how to destroy a man
whether or not
the fact that that book exists i don't
know how many women have read it you
don't know how many women have read it
ish doesn't know how many people have
read it like we just don't know how many
women have read it so it's like
is it now time to protect ourselves well
you know what i think would stop a lot
of this if men could do a financial
abortion women women have the right not
to be a parent
so so i think like a lot of these girls
are doing this because they're trying to
get a check
so if that happened if there was a
financial abortion sorry speaking to the
mike please imagine if men could say
right yes i had sex with this woman but
i don't want to be responsible for the
child if there becomes a child
how many more single parents would well
women do that they say i yes i hooked up
with this man but i don't want to be a
mom i'm going to kill it
they can do that up to six months he's
truly true
so if we can if we can do that then [ __ ]
then he should be able to do the same
thing
but the man and we shouldn't be doing it
they're already doing it yeah but they
don't but they that's what they're
saying but the man
you control having the child or not so
he can't do it he might get you pregnant
but you have the power to
exactly no i don't believe in that
statement i don't believe men get women
pregnant know what i mean
no absolutely 100 the fault of the woman
if you get pregnant if you get pregnant
that's on you as a woman 100 percent
it's not a man
so i'll tell you how i'll explain how
i'll explain how so
the first time i heard that i was like
what do you mean but if you think about
it
who knows
when you're like the time that you're
fertile
yeah the woman does
sorry it's your job if you if you don't
want to get pregnant if you don't want
to um
if you don't want to get pregnant period
is your job to voice that to the man
and then if he and certain obviously in
certain situations there's
there's things that happen to where
a woman gets pregnant and it wasn't
it was just a message
every woman is head of security for
their own vagina
every woman is head of security right
and the only the only if it's not a
great situation
you let somebody in
just like there's a door here
if it's not a burglar situation
someone let someone into this place and
hang on and hang on and the
responsibility for letting if you didn't
vet the person properly or if they
didn't show their id and you believed it
you didn't look at the id that's on you
because once they run up in your house
and burgle your house that's going to be
on you
you have to be hang on but no but you
have to be
head of security for your own vagina and
so if you keep letting men who are not
worthy up into your vagina and shooting
up your club that's your that's on you
iuds are more than 99 effective
get an ied
yeah but then someone will argue not me
per se but someone will argue oh that
affects my hormones that affects my hair
okay then go and then so does a baby
yeah
baby affects your whole life
you know like sometimes the fat's effect
one at a time one at a time guys
an iud or whatever hormones you're
putting into your body affect your body
and that can affect you later on in life
then having a child
that
with the wrong person in a single parent
at home yeah i would pick the iud two
children with a very wrong person but i
love my children
to the deaf of me and maybe not to the
deaf but i mean i love my children okay
and i think they're amazing people and
i'm grateful that i have the opportunity
to actually
raise my children in a different way and
some people may not agree with me
stopping contact but that is what i have
to do to be able to do that
and
i would rather have my children now than
be bleeding for the rest of my life and
in pain
and having possibly other complications
in my body
just so that somebody
could well we're talking about
accidental pregnancy i'm not talking
about
like the guy the choice between a guy
beating you and like you know talking
about the beat yeah but even even the
actual having the child obviously it's
come from um non-protected sex right so
my point is
i could have been protected and as well
it's like does that not show you how men
can be coercively abusive in the sense
of how many men have said how many men
have said let me just put a tip in
and they keep going
and how many women have said okay like
why are you telling me
what's happening like no i mean i'm
saying like that was a choice like you
don't have to deal with those guys
so
so
i'm saying like that's a choice you
don't have to deal with those guys like
so so that that's a personal choice
and and another thing as well you see
you just you've just said it there
you're still in control that
understanding of circumstance you're in
control if he sees the children or not
if it was the other way around this is
why we this conversation we're having
today if you was like that
you're still in control
so we don't have the control of having
our own children when we want to see
them yeah but he also has control no one
has control in the sense of if you want
to see your children
you go to the court no but if he doesn't
but you don't have to stop looking into
the mic sorry but this is my point right
there and like you see because i know
your circumstance and what he's done i
don't know so i can only believe what
you don't actually know you know what
she told you yeah yeah exactly that's
what i can only believe what you're
saying
no no you don't even have to because i'm
just saying
based on what you're saying you're
saying he can go all of that is a
process i've had to wait months to go to
cool and all that mental and time
it affects your psyche and depending on
what kind of person it is so it's like
all you got to do is that's a lot in
itself those children are still sitting
at home with you
no but again
so many options it wasn't just a process
no no no i heard you clearly i'm saying
i get what you're saying you're not one
of them ladies trying to not let him
sing he's been abused i heard that but
what i'm saying is that what we
everyone's disc what the discussion is
is that you see because it's on the
man's side of things this is not
discussed about missandri and how
parental alienation are women because
always see the men always the deadbeats
if the women sit around in the room
until he don't do this he don't pay
women will be like yeah yeah yeah jonah
said generally speaking because it's not
a woman so what i'm saying it's until
when a man come and speaks about it so
oh he's actually doing more than just
being a weekend father do you know what
i mean so that's not what it is i rate
the men that are like that so much
because at least you're fighting for
your child but not every man can fight
no every man wants to fight
women don't have to fight for their
children but at the end of the day for
your child you will fight i'm fighting
for my children
i'm protecting them no but they mean i
get you you protect them in the home but
you're not fighting
against someone taking them from you
you're you're as a mother instinctively
you love you and and cherish your
children and nurture them technically i
am because he's threatened to and he has
tried to okay but the thing is of you
yeah i'm just saying you keep making it
so personal we're trying to talk general
like
like we're not saying that your
situations don't exist we're just saying
that you know generally yeah when men
are fighting for their children they
have a certain threshold when men are
fighting for something that they love
they have a certain threshold even if
it's with a woman after fighting for a
woman for solomon you know what forget
about it i'm not doing it right so it's
the same with children it's not the fact
that they don't want to see their
children it's a fact that they're in a
situation where they're not willing to
fight anymore and when it comes to that
women need to understand that every man
has their limits so if you push the man
to the limit and then he says well you
know what don't worry about it then
she'll go around saying oh he's a
deadbeat dad it's like no hang on he
wasn't actually a deadbeat dad he
actually wanted to fight for children
you i'm not talking about you but you as
a woman made it so hard for him to see
his child that he said you know what
keep them you know i can agree with that
because there are some women where say
for example their children are taken
away because they have neglected them or
they've abused them or whatever it is
and they have the option to do the right
thing to get the children back they
don't fight they go out they go out
raven they go out smoking drinking
whatever it is and they don't do enough
to get their children back so i do get
what you're saying